at the story from the independent i
think it's it's important to talk about
youtuber ethan klein calls joe rogan a
piece of ish for vaccine misinformation
rogan's fan hit back after klein calls
out how podcasters logic makes no sense
i appreciate you bringing back ish by
the way well luke did actually i looked
it up it's one of my favorite words
i can't say much here it's deserved it's
deserves my vocabulary has been cut in
like 25 of it has been cut so so ethan
klein the host of h3 he's still working
hit out at podcaster joe rogan saying
joe rogan who lives on elk meat egg yolk
and human growth hormone with lungs full
of tar thinks he's healthier than
everyone this mf or shab that when he
got coveted he threw the kitchen sink at
it if you're so healthy just write it
out like you say a man should do this
caused so much vaccine hesitancy and
misinformation and he doesn't even have
the balls to stand by the issue preaches
now he's on his show talking about how
fat people should just die of covid due
to such an effing piece of s
um
is i mean i i does i have a legitimate
question that's not a dig is ethan klein
saying this because he's an unhealthy
overweight individual yes sounds like
and so like it was like when joe rogan
was talking about being overweight and
unhealthy was bad for you
i think people yeah people take it
personally so if you understand if you
understand um
uh
sociosexual hierarchy right this is
typical gamma male rage against an alpha
male right this is the basic idea of you
know someone who's kind of at the bottom
of the food chain in in terms of
preference uh lashing out at someone who
is higher up on the food chain from them
and it's it's very simple you see this a
lot um with youtubers but not just
youtubers in general that's just they're
more ubiquitous these days um you see it
everywhere you see it in real life you
see it in you know
office hierarchy you see it in high
schools colleges political leadership
that's when it's scary to an extent well
political leadership is a little bit
different though because political
leadership isn't
is not
conducted because just because of
someone's um you know health and prowess
and and accomplishment right there's all
these like byzantine rules and wait i
mean look at you know we've got like the
peter principal presidency right now joe
biden was not picked because he's our
most competent leader right um that's
not exactly how we got there so for
ethan klein to lash out it's totally in
line if you understand socio-sexual
hierarchy that being said my question is
he says lungs full of tar is is joe
working a smoker i didn't yeah
oh that's right that's right i'm pretty
sure he does smoke cigarettes but does
he inhale
i don't know you don't have really
you're not supposed to yeah obviously so
how would your lungs be filled with tar
then i don't know but we should also
point out that this is some of the
stupidest advice given out by ethan
klein that absolutely makes no sense
you're telling joe rogan not to take
medicine that a doctor is telling him to
take this is the paradox of what he said
uh ethan klein is not a medical doctor
no one here is a medical doctor no we we
all have our opinions
hell no
but ethan klein to be like joe rogan
shouldn't give medical advice you should
you should not listen to an image and
listen to them it's like bro you
shouldn't be giving medical advice oh
yeah he should be hit by youtube in
terms of services
look look up what the medical background
of the ceo of pfizer is what is it
just a veterinarian boom oh he's a
veterinarian he's a veterinarian
and a salesman a very good one
interesting joe is uh
he's a healthy guy yeah that's just i
mean he's great i saw a uh instagram
video of him doing a front kick couple
years ago he looks like he's 42 years
old yeah he's great he exercises all the
time now there i mean you could you can
certainly talk about you know uh your
opinions on diet and whether or not you
know eating so much red meat or whatever
is good or bad but for for ethan klein
it's good too paradoxically it's
actually a bit ironic i suppose of him
to be like joe rogan's an idiot for for
saying these things when he's quite
literally a podcaster saying the exact
same things in the other direction it's
the same problem
like you should not be you know you know
a lot of people have pointed out the
goal of what he said was to generate
press and it worked here we are talking
about him obviously the media is writing
about um
you know congratulations explain to me
what's wrong exactly with egg elk meat
egg yolks and hgh okay i don't know oh i
don't know i i like that i can tell i
was using that as
as an insult
he like wrapped he's saying he's not two
nascent ones in with like a more
controversial one and it's supposedly
it's like yeah no it's just somewhere
like
again it's like it's like bro you're on
the side of of gmos you're on this like
you would be on the side of the sackler
family early on in the oxycontin debate
when it comes to this how dare you be
against the sacklers i don't i don't
think he tweeted for attention i think
it's it's like the people tweet because
people tweet oh let's get them about
rage dude no i'm 100 well sure sure i
was not thinking about any of that stuff
he's an unhealthy guy who clearly does
not eat right or exercise joe said
that's a huge comorbidity and ethan got
upset about it and said who are you to
criticize me when you know you won't
take the vaccine or whatever explain to
me the pathology right and i've still
been trying to actually find find this
one and if anyone's in the chat who has
this i've been i because i always try to
examine the various like there's you
know dr mullen talked about mass
formation psychosis but there's also
like narrow formation psychosis there's
all these different little bands of
pathologies around in our society today
in this uh post-industrial society that
we have and so
the the interesting one that i found is
like show me a guy who looks like ethan
klein who's like triple vaxxed you know
giga vaxxer who's eaten ubereats and
doordash all the time
and yet will scream their head off about
you being unvaxed as a threat to their
health
what is the pathology there of someone
who clearly has not done taken one step
to change their personal behavior
demand that you change yours the cdc has
said around 30 of covet hospitalizations
are in the obese yes cnn just came out
with a report this is what rogan was
commenting on that obesity is a huge
contributing factor to hospitalizations
and even death
i don't understand why ethan should be
mad about that he's he's saying now he's
now he's on a show talking about how
fast people should just die off code
yeah i'm pretty sure joe rogan didn't
say that if joe rogan said that that
clip would be aware right right joe
probably was like you gotta get healthy
man you know start eating better we want
to talk about national exercise you know
mandatory exercise 10 minutes
calisthenics mandatory calisthenics all
right let's go let's go i see luke's
smiling
i wouldn't do it just because the
government made me do it even though i'm
exercising right now that's what i'm
thinking about is like poland does not
comply you know whatever i think that
ethan wants in on the conversation i
feel like he missed the boat into the
intellectual dark web because he's a
smart enough guy but his joking kind of
idiocy persona thing is keeping him out
of the club and he's angry about it like
dude you guys don't even know if the idw
is like the idw is a thing for people to
like attack but it hasn't actually been
a thing for years yeah just the idea of
like a smart a group of really
intelligent podcasting people that are
communicating and have kind of a
community ethan kind of i think he wants
in on that however speaking of which i
believe the both weinstein brothers
signed up for getter
oh did they yeah both i mean
the big story would be daily mail when
oh yeah when services start signing up
yes it's no longer just people
high-fiving each other you can actually
use the service tools because they've
because they've realized though
that from a corporate perspective that
hey we can make money off of this all
right and that's as simple as that and i
think i think once you've crossed that
bridge not now you're the dick we we got
to get our crew to set up that uh uh set
up that account so we'll we'll we'll hit
up the guys um we're actually uh we
normally don't announce guests in
advance so i won't give any specific
dates but we're gonna have the getter
guys on the show nice or get a guy
yeah
yeah luke to talk about keep your
questions ready for those guys man and
in real time
um
start working on advertising yeah i
don't like i don't i don't work for
those guys or anything i just i like it
um i think we'll get a lot of traffic
there yeah with your experience with
mine yeah just nail them if you can
start ringing in an advertising program
and get these people paid man this
thing's going to take off
but yeah i want you to open source your
code and then
that's the big the big move is is um
i think if we start putting all the
articles we write at timcast.com on
getter then that's going to be huge for
us we're going to see way more traction
because people are going to be using it
but it gives you a reason to be on
getter and then you can track you know
you can compare i think engagement will
be massive i think if i'm telling you
i've seen it
when i post to twitter et cetera my
various platforms getter is huge but
it's way better if they're able to to do
that but also implement transparency and
accountability for a lot of their
decisions that would put them over the
top because people will now know that
there is some some kind of
accountability some kind of
responsibility on the individuals and
you will clearly know what you can and
cannot say big tech now kind of works in
this mysterious way where they let other
people like ethan klein give medical
advice and other people like congressmen
and medical doctors and key innovators
of the mrna vaccine technology be
censored on that platform for what i
think this is wrong somewhat zap doctor
malone that's cool though
phd scientist robert malone banned from
twitter ethan klein dude on youtube not
no no and i'll even go this far to say
tim poole dude on youtube not i post so
much random crackpot insanity on twitter
and i'm like i don't even know how i
still have an account but they banned
scientists and sitting members of
congress that's yeah the system is
broken and and again what um
ethan klein is criticizing here is a
cocktail that according to aaron rodgers
who also came out and said that he reads
ann rand today by the way uh just
another shout out here but but most
importantly what i wanted to mention
here that kind of avoiding better
literature
jack don't get me started here
most importantly what aaron rodgers also
said is that nfl teams are secretly
using the joe rogan kitchen sink
cocktail so this is something that ethan
klein is is criticizing that of course
has helped a lot of people it helped
dana white it helped aaron rodgers it
helps a lot of professional football
players according to aaron rodgers
within the nfl so so
why are you criticizing this how is this
your attack point here i don't i don't i
don't care about aaron rodgers opinion i
guess you got the jersey behind him i
don't care about the nfl's opinion i
care about the fact that they were
prescribed something from a doctor
so there when the memes go out and they
say like oh my doctor doesn't know
anything about this my response is
always dude if you hired a carpenter who
couldn't tell you what a tool was or
what kind of wood you were using you
wouldn't hire that person if these it's
crazy to me that this position of you
mentioned this earlier ethan klein is
rogan should not have listened to his
doctor that's insane no you should
listen to a trusted medical professional
you get second opinion but what is the
response joe should have been like ethan
klein is right doc i'm not gonna listen
to you i'm gonna listen to ethan klein
imagine imagine joe rogan walking up to
his anybody walking up to their doctor
with ethan klein's tweet printed out and
saying i'm sorry sir but ethan klein
this paragon of health virtue has told
me and don lemon and don lemon right
uh i actually um whatever tell you my
doc the story when i met don lemon
no yeah so i um i'm a zap when i was
still at one america news
we uh bought a table at the white house
correspondents association
i believe it was 2018. oh yeah so right
after i started so i'm there this was
the one where they made fun of sarah
sanders for her um her eye shadow do you
remember that and that became a whole
thing and she was like on stage they had
this like horrible comedian so
in between that kathy griffin was there
i was sitting next to the right the
table right next to me by the way was
david hogg funny enough so in our chairs
were like almost like directly next to
each other it's funny um
and he's kind of quiet and um
so
in between the different you know
speeches everybody would run to the
bathroom and so you know all the dudes
and you're all in tuxedos and you're
waiting in line it's a men's room but
like everybody's like kind of like uh
you know like like you recognize
everybody in line even if you don't know
them kind of situation and then all of a
sudden don lemon just walks up and he
goes excuse me excuse me excuse me i'm
done loving and just pushes this way
dead serious ahead of everybody who's in
line every correspondent excuse me
excuse me i'm downloading excuse me
actually saying that excuse me and then
just walks right in front of the whole
line he should have been like you
shouldn't use me and he wasn't he wasn't
part of the show he should have turned
anything and took his hand and said oh
i'm jack nice to meet you i'm jack great
to meet you man yeah give him a hug like
yeah like a little time to touch your
shoulder what are you doing about the
show yeah
and it was like you're introducing
yourself it was like and i mean just
head
not even making eye contact with anybody
just like
uh i'm ahead and you all know people let
him cut everything let's let's make a
passage that none of us ever would come
like that you guys when i when i was i
wasn't like he was like a host or part
of the show or anything like that i say
this all the time to people if you are
in line anywhere and cut people they
will do nothing
people do not want confrontation you can
uh it's always been the craziest thing
that people wait in lines i'm kind of
the guy that'll say something
because you're just concerning all these
people because i say something i say
something
in the united states yeah when i was in
russia there was no line although i did
i did russia the line is your elbow
right so china
from a mad dash and it's like a royal
rumble when you're kind of getting those
little old ladies when you're trying to
get on the subway if like i'm telling
you they've got low center of gravity
and i'm telling you they would come
right over
when i was traveling i was going from uk
to moscow to ukraine
and in the west when they were like now
barney group one group one walks over
and they get in now barney group two and
then yep two gets up
in russia they were like now boarding
group one and every single person rushed
full speed it was a massive people
shoulder to shoulder pushing each other
out of the way and i was like all right
here we go and then i just i'm i'm used
to being in the crowd and if you don't
do that by the way you're not getting on
the plane that's right or you're getting
on last you're not going to or you might
yeah you might get on last you won't get
overhead space and so i was like all
right if this is the game we're playing
and i just shoved through everybody and
then boarded like right away i was like
okay yeah people don't understand that
the whole concept of like waiting in
line and waiting your turn that is
totally a western thing and it's a very
american thing outside the country does
it do not exist thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time
you